[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando pensiamo alla parola confine
possiamo intenderla in due modi da un
lato
immaginiamo un divieto un cartello che
dice di qui non si passa
oppure possiamo immaginare un'asticella
da superare una barriera che divide due
mondi delle colonne da oltrepassare
direbbe ulisse morsi da una fame di
conquistare qualcosa di nuovo ecco sarà
che fin da piccolo i miei genitori mi
hanno insegnato a non sentirmi mai sazio
non sentirmi con la con la pancia piena
sta di fatto che la mia vita è sempre
stata caratterizzata da questa fame di
oltrepassare i confini e di scoprire
cose nuove e questo è quello che cerco
di trasmettere anche i miei figli mi
questa fame ha sempre caratterizzato la
mia vita la prima questa fame mi ha
consentito di terminare gli studi
lavorando in prima del dell'ordinario
tempo con cui si concludono gli studi
poi in regione lombardia
un'esperienza incredibile nel superare
nel tentare di superare quotidianamente
il limite il confine di essere percepito
da fuori come il burocrate che ruba lo
stipendio e all'interno di cercare di
spingere i colleghi a mettere in
discussione il normale modo con cui si
fanno le cose
ecco quindi i confini o scatenano la
fame del mettere in discussione il si è
sempre fatto così
oppure possono iniettare una sorta di
anestesia in cui auto giustificare il
fatto che va benissimo continuare a fare
così e quindi la differenza tra l'essere
protagonisti della realtà o essere delle
semplici comparse ma l'esperienza più
interessante personale e quella che è
iniziata tre anni fa siamo a marzo 2016
l'expo di milano è appena concluso
quindi i risultati straordinari milano
sta vivendo un dinamismo economico e
sociale che non viveva da anni
eppure proprio in quel luogo un milione
di metri quadri dove si sa se dovessi
hai raggiunto questo successo si rischia
di essere di fronte alla più grande
delusa una grandissima delusione di
proporzioni globali un milione di metri
quadri non si ha un'idea di sviluppo e
siamo lì nessuna prospettiva aree expo
era la società che aveva acquisito le
aree e doveva aveva il compito di
cercare un privato ha fatto una gara
tradizionale e nessun privato si è
affacciato l'unica certezza per i
privati per gli investitori privati era
proprio l'incertezza delle regole e dei
tempi con cui investire qualche miliardo
e allora quale sfida più interessante
che superare un confine di questo tipo
allora da un lato non bisognava a
deludere le aspettative di expo
dall'altro c'era la possibilità di
realizzare un progetto che diventasse un
po il simbolo della credibilità della
pubblica amministrazione italiana
dall'altro attirare degli investitori
privati e delle risorse private oltre
quelle pubbliche e poi realizzare un
progetto di lungo periodo che diventasse
un po il simbolo della rigenera un
modello di rigenerazione urbana da
esportare anche nel mondo e in ultimo
consolidare e rilanciare milano come un
luogo di innovazione e allora torniamo a
tre anni fa siamo il primo aprile 2016
io lavoravo in regione lombardia
ero vice segretario generale arexpo era
una scatola vuota non aveva né
dipendenti né sedi lavoravo con giuseppe
bonomi e insieme decidiamo di
raccogliere questa sfida costruire da
zero una società di sviluppo
territoriale costruire tutto il processo
che portasse alla realizzazione di un
progetto di lungo periodo andando a
cercare le risorse e il partner
i partner le risorse finanziarie
comunque realizzarla dove avevamo in
mente
dovevamo partire da una visione la
visione intesa sia come prospettiva ma
anche come immagine di qualcosa che non
c'è ancora ma che tu vedi e che agli
altri sembra irrealizzabile
avevamo chiaro che dovevamo costruire un
luogo che non fosse la sommatoria di
edifici fisici ma che fosse un luogo con
le sue relazioni con tutte le sue
dinamiche economiche sociali pensiamo
prima a questo che agli edifici
dovevamo però trovare le parole giuste
per identificare questa visione e allora
abbiamo pensato eco sistema
dell'innovazione poi l'abbiamo definita
mind milano innovation district mind è
proprio un insieme lo abbiamo immaginato
come un insieme di spazi fisici e di
relazioni in cui la connessione tra i
protagonisti dell'innovazione creano una
cultura dell'innovazione per favorire la
ricerca il trasferimento tecnologico e
lo sviluppo un ecosistema
dell'innovazione basato principalmente
su tre ancore pubbliche un campus
universitario con 20.000 studenti delle
facoltà scientifiche dell'università
statale di milano un grande ospedale con
le funzioni di ricerca come galeazzi con
600 posti letto 10 mila persone al
giorno
il cantiere è già partito è già pieno
regime e sarà completato nel 2021 e
infine un grande istituto di ricerca
sulle scienze della vita lo human techno
pole in cui 1.500 ricercatori da tutto
il mondo vengono lì a lavorare sulle
frontiere della medicina e della
nutrizione personalizzata per prevenire
curare le patologie più complesse del
nostro tempo
i primi ricercatori si sono già
insediati e il progetto sarà regime tra
4 5 anni quindi un ecosistema
dell'innovazione basato sulla qualità
della vita
da un lato concentrando le competenze
scientifiche proprio sulle scienze della
vita
dall'altro però anche l'occasione di
mettere insieme
competenze scientifiche e industriali
per la costruzione della città del
futuro
mind sono un milione di metri quadri
quindi le dimensioni di mind con in
aggiunta alla infrastrutturazione
ereditata da expo rappresenta un unicum
a livello internazionale per
sperimentare le innovazioni che
caratterizzeranno le coste la
costruzione delle città del futuro nuovo
modo di muoversi di lavorare di studiare
di stare insieme una grandissima
occasione
ecco per per attuare una visione di
questo tipo
avevamo bisogno però di innovare gli
strumenti amministrativi pur dentro il
quadro normativo attuale ci siamo
inventati una procedura per costruire
una partnership pubblico privato in cui
il pubblico resta proprietario dell'area
e il privato si prende l'impegno di
progettare realizzare e gestire nel
tempo investendo più di 2 miliardi di
euro
e allora quali le novità di questa
partnership pubblico privato allora da
un lato il pubblico resta proprietario
del asset su cui ha fatto ingenti
investimenti e dall'altro ciman si tiene
il rischio autorizzativo che troppo
spesso tiene lontani i proprio gli
investitori privati per l'incertezza dei
tempi arexpo nasce proprio per garantire
tutto l'iter autorizzativo in modo tale
che il privato si concentri sul proprio
rischio che è il rischio finanziario e
industriale
il privato al privato gli viene chiesto
non solo di progettare questo sviluppo
ma anche di realizzarlo pensate a quante
volte su grandi aree si sono pensati dei
grandi progetti che poi sono rimasti nel
cassetto perché non c'erano gli
investitori che potevano realizzarli e
non solo progetta e realizza ma anche
gestisce nel tempo al privato gli viene
chiesto di gestirlo per 99 anni quante
volte succede che gli investitori
costruiscono e poi scappano
dall'investimento vendono e non si
curano del fatto che questo valore
creato resti
tempo questo ci ha consentito di
selezionare un partner internazionale
come lend lease è una è uno dei più
grossi developer al mondo che oggi
gestisce più di 70 miliardi di dollari
di investimenti di rigenerazione urbana
e nelle più grandi città del mondo per
realizzare un progetto che non è una
semplice trasformazione urbanistica ma
proprio una trasformazione economica e
sociale del territorio
ecco per attuare questa questo progetto
la parola clai chiave è sicuramente la
flessibilità flessibilità degli
strumenti urbanistici che non possono
irrigidire un progetto così dinamico con
gli iter autorizzativi e dall'altro però
flessibilità anche del modo di
progettare costruire la città pensiamo
per esempio perché anche gli spazi
fisici
oggi si devono adattare a queste
dinamiche in continuo cambiamento del
modo di lavorare di studiare di vivere
pensiamo per esempio al tema della
mobilità ma in the sarà un luogo in cui
ci vivranno e lavoreranno 60mila persone
ma se noi facessimo dei parcheggi come
li stia come li facciamo oggi interrati
faremo una roba assurda e allora stiamo
progettando i parcheggi di questo luogo
non interrati ma in modo tale che domani
possono essere trasformati in altro
probabilmente l'investitore che viene
investire poi scappa annunci
non ci penserebbe dunque un modo nuovo
di concepire gli spazi pubblici e
privati ci ha portato a pensare un parco
che non è una mera compensazione
ambientale del costruito ma diventa un
asset che connette le diverse funzioni e
dall'altro che diventi un vero e proprio
luogo del lavoro e della vita
nassetta proprio del veli di quel vivere
e dall'altro abbiamo pensato che tutti i
piani terra di questo luogo si hanno
degli spazi aperti sia negli edifici
pubblici che in quelli privati proprio
perché devono diventare luoghi che
favoriscano le contaminazioni tra i
diversi protagonisti dell'innovazione
tra gli studenti lavoratori i
ricercatori ma non solo tra di loro ma
anche aperti alla gente del territorio
perché il territorio la gente la gente i
cittadini devono poter respirare questa
cultura dell'innovazione che non è che è
una grande occasione di sviluppo
dell'intera società e non un privilegio
di un'elite minoritaria di scienziati
quindi mind sono le persone che ci
vivono e ci lavorano gli spazi fisici
devono essere fatti su misura per chi ci
vive allora noi decidiamo di viverci
vogliamo viverci
e per questo che abbiamo fatto un
progetto mindlab per coinvolgere da
subito le imprese che vengano subito a
sperimentare le proprie innovazioni
hanno già risposto 117 imprese per
venire a sperimentare nuovi modi di
pensare la città e l'altro progetto è
mind education noi abbia da subito
vogliamo che le nuove generazioni gli
studenti dalle dalle scuola primaria
all'università siano protagonisti di
questa sfida e non solo siano
protagonisti perché ci vivranno ma la
loro creatività e fondamentale nella
costruzione della città di domani perché
le dinamiche delle nuove città saranno
delle dinamiche delle nuove generazioni
non nelle nostre non della nostra ecco
queste sono le sfide che abbiamo
lanciato alle istituzioni alle imprese e
alle persone affinché
il nostro territorio questo territorio
milano la lombardia al nostro paese sia
guardato da tutto il mondo come un luogo
capace di guardare il futuro con
positività ma non solo di guardarlo ma
di saperlo creare e costruire senza
sentirsi con la pancia piena ma con la
voglia sempre di superare nuovi confini
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]